i literally didn't even listen hear your
question
it's so hot
ah
say that again
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by will ferrell he's
a comedy icon with a storied career and
tv and film that spans decades and he
has a new film it's called downhill in
theaters february 14th go check it out
but first the wings of death will
ferrell welcome to the show thank you
thank you sean how do you handle your
heat well
i enjoy spicy food to an extent
yeah how about yourself well i i do by
vocation i do have to say
uh i i do have a
a very active ulcer right now
so i don't know if that will be an issue
not at all don't even worry about it
great and i should say full disclosure
yeah we were supposed to do this
interview with will and julia louie
she's under the weather and you cannot
be taken on the wings of death
when you're under the weather you know
no there's no way there's no way so the
interview might be a little funky today
yeah we're calling it audible we got
we'll do it and we're gonna make it work
absolutely
[Music]
[Music]
okay the classic no big deal
delicious
no no problem no problem
[Music]
so i'm curious about the production
process on downhill the behind the
scenes photos they're beautiful same
with the trailer i know it was shot in
austria but i do have to imagine that
shooting in the slopes like that day in
and day out there had to have been some
logistical challenges absolutely yeah it
was um
i mean you know we were shooting most of
the movie outdoors you lose
the light right around 3 30 4 4 o'clock
in the afternoon shooting in the winter
time so a lot of 4 35 a.m wake-up calls
to get on a huge snow cat to you know to
be on the side of the mountain as the
sun was rising and it was great it
actually we used all the elements to to
our benefit uh when paul rudd was on the
show he made an interesting point about
how often times the funniest moments in
films are ones that run up against
things that are inherently difficult or
sad what's the appeal of a movie like
downhill where oftentimes the humor is
wrapped up in drama that's very real the
humor really comes from the fact that we
play very relatable characters
everyone's sitting back going oh my gosh
that's my husband or that's my wife and
and uh
and either either fortunately or
unfortunately i've been in that awkward
situation and and you kind of at the end
of the movie in a beautiful way don't
really know what's going to happen with
them which i don't think we find in
movies a lot of times now nowadays
[Music]
i was hoping you're gonna have a tamale
pika
oh lucky you
that was like christmas morning
if
what you gave people on christmas
morning were hot wings yeah
yeah she'll be so lucky
so beyond skiing i know that you're a
huge sports fan and then you even
studied sports broadcasting in college
do you remember how you discovered harry
carey and then what do you think is his
most unique trait as okay
sadly the tamale pika that's just number
two is already doing a number
that's just two i know
okay
julia left you hanging over here can i
just i'm gonna have a little go out here
go ahead
sorry the question harry something about
harry carey so i'm a west coast guy i
worked close enough to where my
apartment was so i could drive home for
lunch sometimes i would turn the tv on
at lunchtime and the cubs are one of the
few teams that still does predominantly
day games you know outside of the
fanatical cub fan you don't really you
don't really know who harry carey was
and i just couldn't believe the stuff
he would say in the middle of the game i
remember one time was watching and
he was like
really getting mad at the cubs picture
at the time
the guys who was pitching was named
heathcliff slocum and he was like
heathcliff welcome on the mound
and ball to
oh come on
if he's throwing hard i'm a [ __ ]
and uh
just i was like did he just say [ __ ]
on on a live broadcast
kept watching him and studying him and
just as i went down the road it was
someone who i decided to try to
impersonate yeah well it must have been
such a thrill then when you played those
five spring training games what was the
most thrilling memory from that because
i did think it was impressive how you
fought off that 92 mile per hour yes i
found i fouled gene machi
gma
yes
probably my highlight was getting to i
was playing for the angels at the time
in center field and they actually hit a
ball to me out there and i fielded it
cleanly and hit the cutoff man and it
was like
textbook textbook all right well you
ready to move on not really
delicious
it's a good plug for fiji fire right
mm-hmm well they all get plugs
yeah but they don't have to be good will
oh you know what i mean yeah yeah you're
right do you want to slam a bottle if
you want to slam a label trust me it
gets weird i'm gonna i'm not gonna hold
back
so when we had seth meyers on he talked
about how one of the main roads to
success in comedy it used to be directly
through the improv theaters in chicago
and you started at the ground lanes is
the live stage show still the best place
to cut your teeth and comedy or is that
path more or less given way to the
internet that's a good question i mean i
think
you know i think it's a combination of
both i think uh
now you have this whole other universe
whole other outlet to uh to you know
record sketches or characters and put
them online and have people discover it
that way at the same time there's just
no substitute for
you know honing your craft in front of a
live audience and
getting that immediate feedback uh if
your aspirations are being on a show
like saturday night live it's invaluable
for us at the growlings it was it was
much more of an emphasis on writing
sketches
improv kind of came
secondary so by the time i got to
saturday night live
i
that was i had a huge advantage i knew
how to write for myself which
isn't always the case it's not like you
show up at that show and they assign you
three riders just to take care of you
it's it's very much feast or famine
so
you know i would encourage
trying
all of those
all of those mediums in a way
does it have scotch in it
[Music]
you can only hope
tastes mustardy
right
first you hit that mustard yeah then the
scotch and the starch starts to roll in
scotch bonnet yeah
[Music]
you don't seem to be reacting the same
way i'm reacting well you did bear
grylls right i did imagine if you go out
into the wilderness with bear grylls and
he's freaking out and panicking the
whole time you're not going to stick
with them
all right you're my you're my sherpa
exactly exactly yeah so i have to put up
a hard food but inside i'm melting okay
good good good good
so recently there was a minor internet
controversy when footage came out of
james corden and justin bieber doing an
episode of carpool karaoke except the
range rover it was being towed by a tow
truck oh
i hadn't heard about this
as a comedian that's shocking
as a comedian who's gotten coffee with
jerry seinfeld is he really driving that
car
he's not
it's being pushed from behind
no jerry's actually driving
and he's got these the tiniest little
cameras up here little gopros or
whatever they are
uh but he's actually
driving the car and i
will have to say he's an excellent
driver
he tries to pick a car i was under the
assumption that there are cars that he
owns because he's a big car guy
but he just tries to pick a car that he
feels is is suited to your personality
or something that reflects you in some
way
so he picked me up in a uh
a pinto
ford pinto no he picked me up in some
weird kit car i was like some bizarre
did you take it as a compliment i did i
did that's what's important yeah
all right well are you ready to move on
halfway mark here already okay
this is the los calientes the los
calientes rojo
[Music]
these wings are perfectly aged
delicious dry chicken
[Music]
all right well we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham we're doing dive on our guests
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context okay but you have
sworn off social media altogether i'm
not really yeah i respect it i tip my
cap to it yeah but we still dug i was on
twitter for four days
what made you throw on the towel there
because i was
uh tweeting about something i was
tweeting was promoting some charity
event i was gonna do and people were
like that's not twitter what's twitter
is for stop
we want to hear about your life yeah i
got shouted off twitter i was like i
can't take it i'm off
all right but you know what well you
still have pictures on the internet i'm
sure i do a couple
so on the topic of the cubs here you are
eating what looks to be a slice of lumel
naughty's pizza yup uh for those of you
who enjoy deep dish pizza i think you'll
we'll all agree that
like the first piece
is delicious especially if you're hungry
for pizza and then the second one puts
you to sleep you know ryan dempster gets
a lot of credit for being uh one of the
funnier clubhouses he's very he's very
funny yeah and he i think he gave me i
was throwing up the first pitch he gave
me his glove whoa believe it or not how
nice is that the glove seems kind of
sacred to a baseball player you know i
kind of understand
or whatever an hour later i got 500
bucks for it
who do you think was the funniest
athlete you ever worked with at saturday
night live definitely shaquille o'neal
we did a sketch in which it got it's
actually you you can find it online but
uh it was cut
for time
but
we did a sketch where the cast was i was
in
footy pajamas and the cast is picking on
me and shaq came over and and shoot them
all away and then proceeded to sing a
song called no one hurts my little man
and then picked me up in his arms and
serenaded me
it was very bizarre
i don't want to jinx it but i feel like
i'm doing pretty good
staying on the topic of food what was a
more traumatic dining experience for you
eating that maple syrup and fudge
spaghetti on elf or eating a grilled
reindeer's eyeball when you were
surviving up in the north oh definitely
the eyeball the eyeball
was slimy and gelatinous and then you
crunched down on the cornea
and then you get into that middle
squishiness yeah
yeah there's no question i mean little
maple syrup on spaghetti who cares
a reindeer eyeball
20 miles north of the arctic circle
not good
where's stargazer made
canada
always known for their hot sauce comes
from ontario yep
i call ontario
the mexico of canada
yeah
how's that cause of their hot sauce
not bad
handling i'm okay
doing great we'll take a little sip
go ahead oh wait
so as an eye creeps up on you a little
bit with decades in the comedy game
it's only right with you here that we
verify some of the folklore surrounding
will ferrell okay is it true that the
prosthetic testicles that you got from
the set of step brothers yes your most
treasured keepsake one of you definitely
top five
my definitely a top one
top two
i keep them in a little like trophy case
like you know proper uh you'd see in a
sports member but like you put a
baseball like a sign baseball like a
plastic put it up on a pedestal
exactly where it belongs yeah
now it's not good
is it true that you needed a little bit
of liquid courage to be naked in front
of snoop dogg in old school
no
i actually didn't
but in between takes it took so long to
get snoop dogg out of his trailer
as he was smoking and playing video
games
that out of boredom i just started
drinking
and then is it true that you were a mall
santa for five months in pasadena and
then chris cattan was actually a real
life elf in that yeah chris kattan and i
were he was my elf
and i was i was santa and we just roamed
in and out of stores
and then bringing it back to paul rudd
when he was on the show he told us that
the original concept for anchorman was
actually this thing where there was like
a plane crash in a mountain yeah and you
were surviving like you were being
hunted down by apes
it was going to meet it was going to be
like
a movie about newsmen meets like the
movie alive where they have to survive
in the mountains yeah
and it was all about trying to survive
and get down the mountain while being
stalked by
chimpanzees with chinese throwing stars
needless to say hollywood said no
[Music]
this one has like a
a
warning on it
just so you know
but i love da bomb it's i love the
vernacular
[Music]
this is gonna be terrible i know it
immediately yeah immediately
yeah
let me just hit you with one of julia's
questions
the friends versus seinfeld debate it
rages on the internet i'm not going to
ask you to weigh in but why do you think
there is so much divisiveness between
those fan bases
oh is there
[Music]
i had no idea
fred
awful by the way
right yeah terrible
uh
[Music]
friends seinfeld groups hate each other
hatfields and mccoys
[Music]
i literally didn't even listen here's
your question
it's so hot
ah
you see
what do you think makes seinfeld so
revolutionary and and long-lasting
uh i think
uh well it was a show about nothing
yeah julia
you're so happy you're not doing this
all right are you ready to move on
let me just careful around your eyes
well
oh yeah right right the cross
pollination yeah okay
fresh thank you
oh wait
[Music]
let me just do this too
[Music]
souvenir
[Laughter]
all right this is the widowmaker
this is from australia
called dingo
dingo got my baby right
what movie was that from didn't go
oh
[Music]
so i know that you pledged delta tau
delta at the university of southern
california right what's one stereotype
about frat bros and the pac-12 that's
completely unfair
i don't
i don't think
there's anything that's unfair i think
they get it all right yeah is it true
that you used to prank your buddies by
dressing up as a janitor and then like
crashing their classes yes yeah did you
like change light bulbs or something or
like how did you not get caught
i uh i just got a hold of a power drill
and i would just wait outside the class
and uh
and um
just you know operate the power drill
and then walk into the class and pretend
to start fixing things
luckily the one teacher that would do to
the clock he loved it and uh
i would just pretend to i was like i
gotta take a care of the electrical
outlet here he's like take all the time
you need
all right well farrell
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
okay
this is a
xxx
the last dab
i'm glad i've already had all three of
my children because i know this will
render you
impotent
[Music]
notice i just put on the outside there
[Music]
oh you're gonna eat it well that's kind
of the point in
putting it on there i thought it was
just more ceremonial
like you just put a little dollop
and just look at it
okay you can do it that way
all right well farrell here we are at
the top of spice mountain and only one
more hurdle to clear yeah we've
discussed your deep roots in improv and
you often talk about how you'll go
anywhere for your comedy and go deep for
your character so with that in mind i'm
curious
was it worth it eating 10 scorching hot
chicken wings
here at the four seasons to talk about
downhill well
i think it's all relative
uh
was it worth it
absolutely not uh
but
i think it's a
i think it was a very unique experience
and uh
it is i've never had an interview like
this no question
well we'll hang our hat i wish julia
could have been here
but you know what will ferrell look at
you coming in here taking on the wings
of death and you still have your feet
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life yeah go see downhill
valentine's
and uh
yeah just remember
hot wings
or uh
bring a bunch of hot wings with you to
the theater
i guess
i don't know i don't know
oh my god great job great job
[Music]
amazing thank you thank you both thank
you all really nice meeting you and
congrats congrats on my
thank you sir i appreciate that
that is the craziest ass [ __ ]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans and i am so excited to
announce that after
years of hard work it is finally here
hot ones the game show on true tv two
teams compete for a shot at hot sauce
glory all the while eating some of the
spiciest chicken wings
ever
there is a lot of sweating a
considerable amount of puking but then
you also have
cash
milkshakes the pepperdome and the place
is going wild hot ones the game show you
do not want to miss it check your local
listings only on truetv
[Music]
you